here's a little weekday motivation from  someone who inspires us hey friends it  is your motivational minute listen drew  and i have talked about this and  something we believe in which is hooking  in it's about finding those moments in  life to really hold tight onto and  believe in yourself and trust that you  have what it takes to make the moments  that you want and that you deserve hook  in hook into those moments that feel  uncomfortable hook into those  conversations that seem uncomfortable  because in those moments you'll have the  most growth ever believe in yourself  trust in yourself and if you doubt  yourself that's okay because you have  the ability to ask for help now that was  inspiring  [Music]